today we're going to be talking about
the proof that NX was not an HTC
building on lots of different things we
were talking about before first let's
recall the definition of a GC so this is
a non uniform computational model so
it's an infinite family of circuits but
that are solving our problem so in a DC
circuit family has the following
properties the eighth circuit C sub n
takes in bits of input and outputs a
single bit okay
you think of this circuit family as
computing some function from 0 1 star to
0 1
there's a fixed D so set every C sub n
has depth at most D so you imagine and
fixing the depth like depth 3 and so
every circuit and this family has to
have depth at most 3 there's a fixed M
so the gates of C sub n or and or not
and mod M so unbounded fan and meaning
about a number of bits going into Egypt
well at least three types of gates and
or ammonium and the mod M operator takes
T bits and outputs one if and only if
the sum is divisible by M okay so think
of D as 3 and M as 6 and this is already
a very interesting and difficult to
analyze class of circuits ok so just
some remarks the default size of C sub
ends you know fixed polynomial and in
okay again there's some problem where
you fix prior to listing all the gates
all of them going to be C sub n we
provided by that polynomial so just to
recall the strength of this model among
those things it smells like this is a
non uniform model of computation so you
can compute some undecidable languages
with it even if you have polynomial
sizes of this kind so a call like our
very simple
undecidable language just needed like a
big and unbounded fan and really in
order to compute
so so that's a strength and it makes it
it makes it possible that you can solve
some very interesting problems but a
weakness is that there is only a
constant number of layers and you have
this you have some you know non-trivial
counting going on but it's only up to
some constant modulus so for example
AECC circuits can be efficiently
simulated by neural networks with a
constant number of layers let's say
three layers for death three so so we
don't think these circuits are powerful
for that kind of reason at least on
individual input lengths but the fact we
get to design a separate circuit for
each input links links makes this a
tricky problem yes no it means that for
every a cc circuit there is a constant
layer neural network which computes the
same function and has roughly the same
size and so on yeah yeah so take any
circuit of n inputs and s size let's
just say your polynomial and s size and
your there was a roughly the same number
of layers computes the same function
yeah so that's what I mean by stimulated
by so like layer is roughly preserved
and size of roughly preserve good any
more questions about the definition yeah
kind of simulation Oh proving so that's
a good question
so proving even lower bounds for depth
to neural networks is largely open
that's a whole other set of this whole
other talk but
so so there's kind of you know let me I
can be more precise so so there's sort
of two ways you can talk about it when
is these things called linear threshold
functions where you have arbitrary
weights on your bits of input and you
and you have some arbitrary target these
alpha sub i's or reals the target is a
real you want to compute whether this is
true or false okay your your gate is
computing this and your weights can be
arbitrary these things can be arbitrary
reals okay then for like an LT F whose
inputs are the outputs of other LTFS we
know of really know where there's
there's no non-trivial balance for this
problem I say you know up to maybe a
let's say a linear number of Wow are
like some small polynomial number of
wires you can prove something but like
say let's say give me n cubed it's in
there's really no non-trivial over
bounce for this they could be is it
could be as powerful this may be
arbitrary circuits but okay just another
side comment so another way to talk
about this would be TC 0 ok that's where
instead of the LTFS
you you have majority gates okay so
without going too far into the details
majority gates you can think of as
having bounds on the weights so think of
having just some small like let these
weights be lets say integers between -
Polly and Polly n ok so think of the
weights is somewhat small this is more
or less like the same as majority now
but for majority of majorities it's well
known since the early 90s that these
things have exponential size lower
bounds okay so like for example you
cannot compute inner product modulo 2
with so like inner product
of two Veck two vectors modulo two needs
at least to the Delta n gates I think
you can set Delta B like at least like
one-third depending on how you set this
thing a bit but yeah for these things
question putting doesn't putting
arbitrary reals on the gates doesn't
that make the ball really weird because
you can attack almost whatever you want
into the real you could but you turns
out you can't because it's a linear
function so without loss of generality
that's another theorem then that kind of
proof
the weights can in fact be made
something like into the let's say theta
n into the theta n okay so you can think
of these as integers in that kind of
range without that's without loss of
generality because there's only two to
the N the input/output you really care
about and so you could set things up is
kind of like an LP to determine what the
weights are then just sort of say how
big to those that big in my solution
possibly get and and so it's actually
yeah okay if you were a more complicated
function than like a threshold and maybe
yeah you'll be in trouble don't have
this back
yeah these are yeah these are just
feed-forward
yeah well that's used to learn the thing
this is this is this is we're assuming
that it's already there and it's fixed
once and for all now we're going to
compute with it
yeah so like we're yeah I'm not talking
at all about like constructing the thing
out yeah I mean well I know it exists me
other than that I mean yeah but but like
what's that this is yeah we're here
we're assuming that all the learning has
been done in fact you know maybe you
know the the deity of your choice
dropped us down from the heavens and now
you're going to compete with it's as
small as possible one and and that we're
good and then we're just going to just
feed the inputs through and it's going
to work as fast as it possibly could any
more questions
alright ok so where does a cc come from
I mean it looks like a weird class like
mod 6y ok so I would like to argue it
grows naturally out of thinking about
how to prove circuit lower bounds okay
now this is a story which you know it's
a story ok it's not necessarily history
ok it's a story ok yeah so so it grows I
have approach where people said you name
it we don't understand Turing machines
so proving peanut when pcs hard like
understanding what Turing machines can
do maybe we understand circuits we
understand and or and not so by
induction we should understand circuits
right so it's trying to prove in p9 and
ppalli ok so the simple combinatorial
nature of circuits should make it easy
to prove impossible or make easier
proven possibility results ok so I tie
first sex tips ER and then later
improved by whole table showed that the
parity function or the mod to function
so summing up the bits modulo two cannot
be done in a cc so it cannot be done in
polynomial size ACC with only an or not
okay so in other words if you leave out
mod two you cannot compute Montu from
from this thing with with a constant
number of layers okay so there was
natural to ask what happens if I give
you the mod to function for free as like
one of your primitives you can compute
with so then reverse broth and Smolinski
showed well if I give you and or not and
mod to you cannot compute Mont three
okay and in general for a P and Q
distinct primes you can't compute mod P
even if you have access to mod Q and
constantly layers and or not okay so
it's natural to say well what happens
that I give you mod three and mod 2 okay
for free okay come on three ma two and
or not this turns out to be equivalent
having in or not in mod 6 ok this if you
just think about it for a moment so mod
to having mod 2 n mod 3
is equivalent just having a Mont six so
Barrington suggested this ACC is the
next step you know allow me any mod M
rather for a fixed constant M let's see
if we can just continue the program he
conjectured that the majority function
so computing the most popular bit the
inputs is not in acc okay so some time
path and this conjecture didn't get
resolved okay it just disappeared okay
so then in the early 90s people started
to say in papers oh let's try to find a
function in NP this not compute limp on
well ACC and some time passing just
think it resolves and you know at some
point someone noticed me with era
calendar that in X was knock in ACC is
still open like we don't know if a
function compiler boy we that we have
like so little progress we don't even
know whether or not in terms the
exponential time its containing the ACC
or not and so over the year is this
ballooned into a very embarrassing open
problem complexity theory which you know
at least we can say that is true okay
all right
reduce the embarrassment just a little
bit okay good so what do we prove so we
call X to the N P is exponential time
with MP Oracle and it's slightly more
probably strictly stronger than an X so
the X is contained in X with an Oracle
for NP okay and X does not interest the
exponential time so you have exponential
long solutions verifiable an exponential
time X into analog of NP so the first
theorem is that there's a problem in
xdmp so that for every fixed depth
everything's module sim there's an
epsilon so that Q doesn't have a cc
circuits with mod M gates let's say SiC
mod six gates step three in size to the
end of the epsilon okay so this epsilon
is governed by this depth in this
modules
so there's some exponential lower bound
this sort of mildly exponential lower
back okay
that's 4x to the NP now the second
theorem is a lower bound for in X but
it's not exponential
not quite exponential so one way to say
is that there's a problem in an X so if
this problem doesn't have quasi pummel
sized 80c circuits of any constant depth
but really in place of this quasi
palawan size you could put any function
f such that you know roughly speaking
okay then make that the problem is my
apps look like parentheses Susan so F of
F of F is it most to the N to take any
function f which is a one way to say
this would be third exponential this is
again roughly speaking it does not have
there's a problem in in extra does not
have F of inside circuits of any
constant jump okay so quasi polynomials
composed with each other three times or
less strictly less than 2 T so maybe
just put low to it in just be alright so
I mean the most natural [ __ ] I can
think of is
all right so we don't quite give these
exponential little balance here right so
so just to put these two theorems in
context let's compare with the following
so it was known since the seventies that
X with an Oracle 4 Sigma 2 P so NP to
the NP doesn't have even like slightly
smaller than the maximum circuit
complexity okay so there are functions
and this big class so this even bigger
class which I don't think my height can
accommodate even ok well what happened
to the screen oh I think I pushed
something ok sorry
so this really big class doesn't so
essentially has functions of maximum
circuit complexity the maximum possible
sir complexity okay
and here we're getting some exponential
lower bound for NP and it was known to
can improve by common in the 80s that in
X in X with the NP Oracle which oops
you know somewhere in here ok doesn't
have plus a poly size circuits okay and
so that that drops down from an extra NP
2 X to the N P for ACC ok and it was
known that the merlin arthur version of
exponential time so think of this is
probabilistic not a turistic exponential
time so you have a proofs of exponential
length but you get to allow to get to
verify them in randomized extensional
time and that's not that's not in Kazi
poly size either okay so that's
somewhere
so we should go down here Oh tear off
Behrman fort now tear off yeah and this
is a Meyer stockmeyer yeah yeah and call
me out if you ever want to know the
initial initials me yeah okay as it is
to put this in context with was no
certainly no lower bounds known for even
in X yeah so here like in X was kind of
like the the small class and all these
big big things okay so what's the proof
strategy by now maybe it would be clear
so the first is to show that faster set
algorithm for AC circuits imply the
lower bounds we want so just to give an
example if we can solve AC set with in
inputs and sub-exponential size and
psilocin tuned in time then X to the N P
doesn't have selection full-size ACC
circuits okay
this is one of the connections we talked
about and the second step is just
designed the faster algorithms you know
basically make the hypothesis is true
okay so so here's like one explicit
version of that statement for all depths
D and moduli M there's an epsilon to the
ACC set one circuits with n inputs depth
D and mod M gates due to the end of the
epsilon size can we solve into the N
minus Omega into the Epsilon time so not
only do we get to the end over end of
the ten we actually get something much
better that we divide by two to the n to
the epsilon roughly speaking so this
Omega D you know is some constant factor
okay and I talked a little bit about the
sillies you know at a higher level maybe
in the I guess in the first lecture
about how the you get the set algorithm
so I want to spend most of the time
talking about how you prove this
connection between set algorithms and
circuit lower bounds
there any questions so you mention X to
the end yeah for NX yeah yeah I'll
mention it yeah basically you would just
put in X doesn't have no circuits F of n
sighs tickets which of this holds yeah
yeah it just yeah this is just an
example of some of the things you
include yeah yeah and in the case for X
EMP this is what you would you would
want to conclude any more questions
right so so now we're gonna look at
house at algorithms imply lower bounds
okay so we want the show again set
algorithms for ACC circuits imply lower
bounds for some function X NP all right
so the proof idea is to work by
contradiction so we we show that if both
of the following are true so if we have
an ACC set algorithm and we had the
small circuits for X to the N P then we
can derive some simulation of
non-deterministic time which is so good
it doesn't exist so well precisely we
can show that every language and
non-deterministic to the end time can be
re wired using the set algorithm and
using the these circuits to run in less
than to the end time okay and this
contradicts the so-called
non-deterministic time hierarchy theorem
says that as you strictly increase the
time you're taking to solve problems
than they are strictly more problems
that you can solve by diagonalization
and the variables that you need here is
Quran terrorism is a little more
complicated than the usual thing so I
think the key concept to understanding
how this proof works so the the main
conceptual barrier to get over is the
particular annex problem we're going to
work with we're going to work with a
specific in X version of the 3sat
problem
okay a compressed version of these a
problem and in this problem
exponentially long formulas are encoded
with polynomial size circuits there so
you think of a pollen and we're gonna
look at its truth table and ask is the
truth table encoding a satisfiable
formula okay and so so this is okay
that's a that's a key concept now I'll
just say more about it now
so given a circuit it takes in bits and
outputs a single bit let TT of C be its
truth table so it's the output of the
circuit on all to the incitements let's
say we line up the assignments in
lexicographical order when we're
printing their outputs okay just to give
some convention on the ordering of the
assignments okay so the succinct 3sat
problem is the following problem I give
you a circuit seat let's say it's over
an or not we want to know that's its
truth table
encode a satisfiable 3-cnf formula okay
so you've got circuit so think of the
circuit is little okay seems like
something Polly in size okay it's got n
inputs and you evaluate this thing on
all to the n inputs okay this gives you
a really long bit string okay and you
want to know under some reasonable
encoding is this a member of 3sat is
this satisfiable 3-cnf formula yes or no
okay so that's the problem so it's those
three CNF formulas that are satisfiable
and have a very succinct encoding okay
that's that's the way to think about
so a theorem goes back to the 80s says
it's the sink 3sat as NX complete okay
so it's solvable in not in terms of
exponential time but moreover there's a
polynomial time reduction from any
language in in X to succinct three-set
polynomial time reduction okay all right
so to see that succinct 3sat is an extra
it's not too hard to see the idea is I
give you this circuit right so you can
evaluate in all to the n inputs that
takes to the N times
paulien time okay that's fine it's all
deterministic exponential time now you
guess a satisfying assignment for this
thing okay so under a reasonable
encoding the satisfying assignment is no
more than two to the n bits to encode it
as well so you guess about no more than
to the n bits encoding a satisfying
assignment then you check the assignment
satisfies the formula that takes
exponential time okay so you had a
non-deterministic guess of about through
the in length you took to the end poly
two to the end time to verify I guess so
it's it's in the next okay that should
be hopefully clear right okay so so
what's interesting is that this problem
is actually in ex parte even under
polynomial time reductions okay so this
basically follows from the following
kind of statement for all languages in
NP there's a very very efficient poly
log time reduction from that language of
three set by poly log time I mean you
imagine you just want the ice bit of the
three set formula okay so you you're
gonna have some reduction it takes some
X so it's rejecting some language to
three set okay and you have some X and
you want to know the ith bit of the
3-cnf formula gonna get from this X is
like some instance of L you want to the
side and
is going to be computable in poly log
length of X so just think like you have
random access to the input and write
because this is a polynomial time
reduction if I want the I bit of a
string which is poly in links it takes
only order log n bits to encode the
index to something of poly in length
okay so I have read this entire index
and I have random access to this thing
and compute the ithe bit of the
reduction from L to be set in poly log
in time so so this is a I mean I will
say more details at least about how this
applies in external moment but it
follows from this basic thing and I mean
the depending on how you set it up I
mean this it takes a bit but I mean to
show this but it it's I mean I think
even the proofs in sip sirs book could
be every wire to to run like this with
random access so I mean most most
pursued like you get the idea is that
that is that like the proof the
cook-levin theorem is extremely local
like if you want to know like what's
going in a clause you really only need
to read like a constant number of bits
from the input and most and to figure
out what like a particular Clause is
going to be if you can clear figure out
what a bigger closet gonna be you can
figure out what a particular bit is
going to be okay so and then from this
statement then by padding by just
padding things up by exponential you
would get that for all languages and in
X there's a polynomial time reduction
from that language to exponentially long
3 set instances ok so then this index
this index here so if you have a in X
language this index here becomes poly
poly in length and this becomes
computable in poly n time so like this
is obviously plus the index length here
ok but it becomes exponentially long tea
set instance alright
now the key observation here is at that
polynomial time reduction which given an
input X and given a
and I to compute the ice bit this can be
described with a circuit in the natural
way so any any polynomial time out
review described as a pollen alive
circuit okay this would be the the
circuit that would give you the succinct
3sat instance okay so you you hardwire
this X and you evaluate at all possible
I you get some truth table that'll be
exponentially long face CNF instance
okay of course I'm not giving details
about this I'm just trying to describe
like conceptually what's going on so
okay so the particular form of this
reduction we're going to use very very
nice strong form proved by in Manuel II
over there and his students so if you
want to know the details just ask you
know I asked him that direction okay so
this is a very strong form of what I
just said and yeah it has the following
description so for any language in in
time to the end there's a polynomial
time reduction from that language this
is seeing three set so that the
following two things hold so first the
reduction does what you think it should
so given something in L it outputs the
circuit that encodes the satsang 3-cnf
formula so it's truth tables
so that's 503 CNF if X is not a tell the
outlet reduction doesn't encode the sync
reset yes and since okay but moreover
you can make this circuit C sub X ACC in
fact you can make it a C 0 with very
little problems in fact they have they
have an even sort of stronger statement
than AC 0 it has some fixed polynomial
size let's say into the 10th and it has
at most n plus 4 log n inputs we're
Innis the original length of the input
you started with okay so so you go from
an X of length in to a C sub X which has
just a small number of inputs extra a
compared to number you know the length
of the input here
and this thing has intense eyes and this
thing has some fixed constant depth and
or not okay so has some tricks depth AC
zero
okay alright so so not only can you show
that this succinct 3sat problem is hard
it's also hard like even if you restrict
to AC zero circuits in this sense okay I
think it's actually somewhat surprising
structural result because AC zero is
supposed to be weak but even NC 0 if you
if you set things up in the right way
yeah yeah so it's just I mean but at the
same time like you know I mean non
determinism is very powerful so there's
a lot of non determinism going on to
make it possible to make the circuit
easy AC zero okay all right okay so a
corollary of this reduction is that the
sync three set for say ACC circuits of
in inputs in intense size so it can be
solved in non-kinetic time to the end
times paulien but it cannot be solved
and say to the end over end of the five
time okay so to see the first statement
well I more or less told you how the
first statement goes so so the first
statement is I've got n inputs and in
the tenth sighs so I just evaluate the
circuit on all possible inputs us to the
end of those okay
that takes paulien time per one that
gives me some big CNF instance I guess a
satisfying assignment for it all right
it has it most that size I verify that
deterministically so it took turistic to
be plain - well why is it not in not in
turn sick to the N over in the five time
anyone any guesses why you have a smile
on your face Mike because this problem
is hard for an ex it's hard for your
next yes
to the end not the turistic time that
part in to the end over 5 yeah but this
specific problems the same 3sat has a
property to as a core layer of this
reduction so so the it's so like the way
you prove this is just by repealing some
non-deterministic time hierarchy see
right so I mean I can give a few more
details about that
maybe too many so so suppose succinct
three-set were in this amount of time to
the end over end of the five none of the
parameters we've chosen okay so take a
language announcers a time to the end we
know we can reduce that thing so let's
say given an instance X of the problem
we know we can reduce it to a circuit C
sub X which has n plus four log n inputs
okay and in the ten sighs right and is a
CC now by our assumption that we have a
fast algorithm we we have a fast
algorithm through the sighting this is
seeing three sentences we just reduced
to okay and how fast does it run well
this thing has got let's call it m input
so n is equal to n plus four login okay
now this n here is the number of inputs
to the circuit that we're solving here
so this thing is going to run so if we
run our sink 3sat algorithm we just do
the reduction here then we run this is
ink reset algorithm it's going to take
what time it's gonna take two to the M
over m to the five time okay but M is M
plus four login
all right that's n plus four log n to
the 5 here that's going to be to the end
times in the four over roughly into the
five that's a little to the end that's
the contradiction right we just took
anything into the end and similarly it
faster than to the N right so the real
key property or one of the main key
properties not only that it's a ECC or
AC zero here is that the number of
inputs here is very very small it means
that the succinct three settings since
you get is at most to the n times n to
the four links right I mean like when
you evaluate all possible inputs that's
this max length
kind of magical machine that transforms
an easy question result that relies on
the concrete yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
I'm just so I'm just saying it this way
so that we could from now on we can just
think about the same three set and try
to contradict this okay that's what
we're going to do so we have this
problem that's solvable to the N times
poly and time with non determinism we're
going to try to show it can even be
solvent to you know in the five time
with non determinism contradicting this
corollary using the assumption that X
the NP a small circuits and we have a
fast set yes yes yes yes absolutely
even in severe yeah yeah yeah I just put
a CC because it's it's sufficient for
what I want to do because I'm working
with the ACC that's all any more
questions
so yeah otherwise we'd cause you cannot
intersect a marquee yes
all right all right so we say that the
sink three sign is a GC Santa Simon's if
the following is true okay so this is
what I would say is a kind of easy
witness argument so so this is a
definition so it says the sink three
said it's a Z sat assignments if for
every seat whose truth tables are
satisfiable 3-cnf there is another ACCC
circuit okay
of size sub-exponential and the original
one such that its truth table encodes a
variable assignment that satisfies the
formula encoded by this circuit okay so
just to unpack this it says it's the
sink three centers AZ satisfying times
just some property which may or may not
be true okay it's going to saying all
satisfiable formulas which are
compressible which can be represented by
small circuits okay have a satisfying
assignment which is also somewhat
compressible okay so it's the same three
centers ACC Satta Simon's if for any yes
instance of the sink three set there's
an ACC circuit that ain't codes and set
a witness to that yes instance okay so
it's truth table is a satisfying
assignment to the formula encoded by
this circuit so just see how she can be
general or or yeah I mean like here I'm
just letting see be general yeah
so so this so this is what I would call
an easy witness so like you've got some
problem it's in Ex complete you you in
this property true you get to say there
is a witness which actually can be
compressed can be represented succinctly
with a small circuit so it's the easy
witness an easily represented witness
okay so so the second lemma we're going
to use is that if we assume X the NP has
smallish ACC circuits then this property
does actually holds the same three set
does have ACC satisfying assignments so
all satisfiable formulas which are
compressible have a somewhat
compressible satisfying assignment so
the essences of sustained 3sat have easy
witnesses provided this circuit upper
bound holds okay so that's sort of where
the circuit upper bound is coming in for
us the assumption that it holds coming
in alright so how does this lemma go
so I'll just sketch over this so the
following can be computed in xdnp
the problem is the fog so we're given a
circuit C and given an eye okay
what we want to do is print the ice bit
of a particular satisfying assignment
for the formula encoded by C so we're
printing the ice bit of a witness to
this distinct three set instance C okay
so we're going to use an MP Oracle and
binary search okay
define not only that this C is a yes
instance for the sink three set so in
other words PT of C is in satisfiable
Florida but in fact we can we're going
to just find the lexicographically first
satisfying assignment to it by repeated
queries to NP taking possibly
exponentially many queries to defined it
okay
so once this is you know sort of a
standard thing I just think you know if
so if we have P to the N P for example
then it's a sort of standard result that
you can compete am P compute the the
lexicographic we first set assignment
to a Sat instance okay bye
binary search and using the empirical
okay so we're just padding that up to
the exponential time right and then once
we've got that satisfying it's time we
just output the eyes a bit
this is computable and xdmp all right
and so by assumption though by
assumption we are assuming everything at
X NP has small AC circuits so there's
some ACC circuit D that actually
computes this function all right so it
outputs the eyes a bit of a satisfying
assignment to any yes instance of the
same 3 set okay so for any circuit let's
say C prime okay define a circuit e
which on I runs D with C prime hard
coded on I okay then that circuit e will
have some exponential size and it will
encode a satisfying assignment ok the
truth table of it is construed as a
satisfying assignment satisfies the
formula encoded by C prime okay okay so
so if X NP has small AC circuits then we
can have small AC circuits encoding
satisfying assignments for any s
instance of the sync $0.03 any questions
about this step
so yeah I mean if you're stuck you just
think you know in P to the N P I can
compute a satisfying assignment between
any given set formula think of how you
would do that and then pad that up to X
and P you know with books the same way
yes I think so
for this T prime it should be s you like
that in up in this double yeah yeah yeah
yeah this would be a super yeah so okay
so now let's give an overview of this
this proof that sat algorithms and PI
lower bound I think we have these limos
in place and let's see how they're going
to be used okay so the first is to
assume we have it this fast is easy said
algorithm okay and we have smaller CG
circuits 4x the MP okay and we're going
to use this to solve the sink three set
on in bits circuits and in time to the
integrator in the five and that's a
contradiction we show that that actually
is just not true you cannot solve the
sink piece at that fast not
intrinsically okay so here's an outline
of how that algorithm is going to go so
we're just going to give an algorithm
for z3 set using these two assumptions
the set algorithm and the small circuits
okay so first given us a sink three set
instance see we're gonna guess a small
agency circuit encoding a satisfying
assignment for whatever formula this c
is encoding for the exponentially long
3-cnf TTS C okay now if this TTFN C is a
satisfiable formula then a small AC
circuit encoding a sat assignment exists
by this limit ooh and the fact we're
assuming we have
small circuits for xnp okay so succinct
3sat has ATC satisfying assignments
under one of these assumptions we're
making okay
so this small circuit is going to be
there so if you just guess it okay
that's only you know sub-exponential
amount of guessing this is a
sub-exponential sized circuit ACC why
okay now then we're going to use the
fast circuit set algorithm to check that
sorry this should be a why the truth
table of the circuit Y satisfies the
formula encoded by C and about to the
innovate in the five time okay so so
we're going to guess the satisfying
assignments to sync the encoded okay
that uses this circuit upper bound
assumption then we're going to use the
fast easy set album to verify that that
guess we made actually does encode a
satisfying assignment okay now we're
just doing that the deterministic
algorithm so if we actually make that
check we can accept and reject normally
okay so this would be a nice non
turistic algorithm such that it runs too
fast you guys in order to the end over
end of the flat time either the overview
clear low views clear the next slide
will be clear all right it'll just have
the details in alright so we're given
this the same three settings in C okay
we can can without whilst you're all you
think of is the ACC circuit itself event
inputs right we just want to prove
that's the same preset instances which
are you know ACC of this form can be
solved in to the N over in the five time
which would contradict and what what we
got okay so we can assume it's a htc
circuit in coding this 3-cnf formula all
right okay next thing we do mean
arthur's we guess this circuit why else
of exponential size okay now this why
again when we give it a j it's supposed
to output the japes bit of some
satisfying assignment okay for this
formula fee encoding the circuit C okay
so this thing again supposed to be a
succinct set
my assignment for the formula encoded by
C okay so now we're going to construct
the circuit D of select central size
that's going to check for us that this
guess we made is correct that Y does
indeed in code is satisfying assignment
okay so we're gonna do this as follows
this D is gonna be in this box okay so
the first thing we do is we have the
inputs for this circuit go in to see
this is seeing 3sat instance okay now
see as defined given an input at Alpe as
a single bit of the fisa Nathanson's but
you know a 3-cnf instance so this is
like the one assumption we make on the
encoding is that you can write the
clauses of this succinct 3sat instance
you mean in consecutive bits of the
thing so so we the one assumption we
make about the encoding of this thing is
that if you want to know I know what's
in the ayat' clause you want to look at
say order in consecutive bits of the
formula okay the the the like the bits
are not scattered throughout the thing
like if you just write down a 3sat
instance in binary this is what you
would get like if you were saying okay
me and then you didn't apply error
correcting code or something - okay so
so that's the only assumption we make is
that if you want to know what the ice
Clause is it's you know easily indexed
into and it's some order in consecutive
bits in the thing okay so given that
we're just going to rig together order
in copies of our to seeing 3sat instance
okay okay so this is indexing into the
clauses of the sistine preset formula we
get and we're going to just drink
together ordering copies of this thing
so it outputs the ice claws the entire
clause on I okay so it just it's gonna
output a single clause okay before it
output a single bit you can rig together
some ordering copies I didn't make it
out put just a whole cloth index by I
okay right
it has most n plus four log in input
bits
indexing into it okay okay so this thing
is printing a clause okay so it's
printing a sign bit for a literal like
whether it's positive or negative and
it's printing what the name for that
variable okay another sign bit the name
for a variable another sign bit the name
for the variable okay three of them cuz
it's 3sat okay 3-cnf all right so let's
say the sign is s and a is the variable
sign but T be the variable U and C
alright so now we have names for three
variables okay so now we just plug those
into copies of Y because Y is supposed
to tell us on a what should we set
variable a to and on B what should we
set variable B to and on see what you
see right so Y on Jason's to output the
Jake's bit of a satisfying assignment so
what do we set the Jake variable to okay
all right so this so now assuming y
works we've got a potential assignment
for a B and C we've got the sign bits
for them so now we just have six bits we
just check whether or not this is going
to satisfy that clause okay so this is
going output assignments to the
variables a B and C of this big formula
fee now with a constant size circuit we
can just check like does notice does
this assignment y satisfy that clause
yes or no okay we got all the bits we
need to check that six of them the sign
bits and the values of variables okay so
now using constant size circuit okay
just take six bits and help us a bit
we're gonna have this the output one if
and only if the assignment encoded by Y
does not satisfy the if' clause let's
see so if it does not satisfy whatever
we plugged in there then we make it
output one okay okay yup and one if it
does not satisfy so so let's think so
what do we do we got some big circuit D
all right and it has an ACC part here
and you see zero part in C zero part
here
see see part here constant size here the
whole thing is a CC AC CC of a CC is a
CC right this thing it's a CC okay
suppose this circuit is satisfiable what
does it tell us this circuit is
satisfiable on some input i what does it
tell us tells us that the clause is not
satisfied by Y right so if it's
unsatisfiable it says that Y actually
encodes a satisfying assignment for all
the clauses so we nearly need to check
that this circuit D is on satisfiable we
check its unsatisfiable that will verify
for all possible clauses it's going to
output 0 so the assignment coded by Y
satisfies that close ok so it satisfies
all the clause so checking this thing is
unset is equivalent to checking that
this excellency longface uniform is
actually satisfiable on the assignment
encoded by Y all right ok so using our
ACC set algorithm we can determine
satisfiability of this circuit D in less
than to the end time okay we we sort of
set things up so that right we put I
think to the N over in the 10 here we're
in a number of inputs so we've got to
the end times in to the 4 in the
numerator we're divided by in the 10
denominator so that's definitely low to
the end ok so once we do that if it's
unsatisfiable we accept ok satisfy what
we reject that's it that's the algorithm
ok and this thing is running faster than
to the entire
in fact the way we setup it runs faster
than to the N over into the 5 time which
is what we wanted to get the
contradiction any questions about so
it's using the extreme local check
ability of 3 set like even though it's a
exponentially long singing encoding
exponentially long computation with
excellence you long witness assuming we
have small circuits the witness can be
efficiently encoded ok and just
unconditionally there is a way to encode
this excellent you long computation in a
very local way is a 3-cnf so we're just
kind of indexing into with only poly an
overhead different steps of the
computation we want to verify and
assuming you have these small witness
circuits we can verify those steps so
it's just you it's using the extreme
local check ability of
okay so let's back to the reproof
strategy so we want to show that faster
sours and ply lower bounds okay so this
is what we just described and we want to
design faster ACC algorithms which
satisfy that bothers us now I already
talked about this in lecture one so
would you like to have like say a two
minute recap of that algorithm again new
two minute recap okay someone gonna try
me so so I want to like get through a
few more things before I'm supposed to
be done but okay all right two minutes
okay so there were two ingredients for
solving AZ set one was a known
representation of a GC which said that
every function computable with a small
AC circuit can be expressed in this form
of G of H s okay where H is a multi
linear polynomial that has a small
number of monomials or smallish number
of monomials okay
so k is quasi-polynomial on the size of
the circuit implementing F so it's quasi
panel not exponential and this multi
linear polynomial takes on some values Z
or through K as I plug in all 0 1 values
ok and then this genie can just be some
arbitrary function like a little lookup
table think that is some kind of filter
that takes quasi following many values
and tells you with the final output of
the circuit is ok so it was that and
there was a fast Fourier transform for
multi linear polynomials which said
given a multi linear polymer H and its
coefficient representation so in other
words I just tell you all the
coefficients of the monomials the value
of this polynomial on all to the
endpoints and 0 1 n can be computed into
the end times poly n time so polynomial
amortized time per assignment instead of
the naive thing which would just be just
evaluated over all possible coefficients
on every single to the end assignment
yeah this it's it's if it only had poly
n coefficients to look at ok all right
ok so
so the algorithm from there from those
two ingredients is a proof by picture so
we're given this circuit so we do some
size input trade-off you take the first
into the epsilon inputs and you try all
possible to the in the epsilon
assignments to them for each one you get
some sub circuit of see what having plug
in those assignments you take it or over
all these sub circuits
okay so you've increased the depth by
one but you reduce the number of inputs
by in the Epsilon okay this is still an
ACC circuit and it's satisfiable if
known as the previous one was alright so
then using this decomposition into G of
HS of beagle and thyroid we get this you
know G which is a lookup table takes
inputs one let's say zero through K
outputs ooh
one we got some multi linear polynomial
we think this a bunch of and gates and
the whole thing is over in - in the
epsilon inputs and then using this FFT
result we can evaluate this G of Ages on
all possible assignments and pollen oil
amortize time per assignment okay so
essentially we just want to check with
this G of H ever outputs one if it
outputs one you know this is going to
output one so we know this is going to
output one on some assignment so it's
satisfiable yeah if you're always up at
zero this always up at zero so that
always help with zero unsatisfied all
right that's that's your three minutes
okay all right okay all right so I
wanted to mention briefly like something
that Russell was talking about how you
use slightly more machinery to show that
with a faster acc set algorithm you get
in explore bounce okay
so right so we get like NX doesn't have
quality poly sizes you see circuits or
polynomial size so you proceed just as
before with Xin P except you don't get
this very simple half a slide proof that
if X NP is small circuits then succinct
three set has small satisfying
assignments you have to work harder than
that so you'd like to prove that if
in X's and P Polly just in X being in
ppalli then succinct VSAT has the sink
satisfying assignment so Polly sized
circuit encoding sassing this is a
theorem of russell valentin na'vi
bickerson from 2002 and it's highly
non-trivial because because the non turn
state computation and you somehow want a
single poly side circuit it's kind of
isolating the particular witness of this
exponential long computation okay you
could have like many possible witnesses
that work you want to poly sizes are
encoding one of them and it's very hard
to figure out how from these Xen p-type
proofs you could get that kind of thing
if you go down to NX so the proof
applies work on hardness is randomness
I'm just going to briefly sketch over it
because Russell talked about it too so
the first step is that if X was in
ppalli then x equals MA Merlin Arthur
yeah that's from B fnw okay which
Russell side at length and the second
step is that if the sync 3 set does not
have poly size set assignment circuits
okay we want to say if n xn P poly and
the scene 3 set doesn't have succinct
circuits encoding SATA Simon's we get a
contradiction okay so if it doesn't have
these set assignment circuits then in
about in time to the end with an
infinitely often a qualifier and n bits
of device qualifier we can guess a
function with high sir complexity namely
a function of witness to some instance
okay which is encoded here we guess a
witness to some instance out there some
succinct 3sat instance and verify that
it works okay once you guess a Sat
assignment you can verify in exponential
time that it works okay so we'll get a
Sat assignment to some hard to sink 3sat
instance that we encode here in in bits
so if we're assuming succinct reset
doesn't have these small SATA Simon
circuits there must be infinitely many
it's a sink three set instances out
there such that all that satisfying
assignments have high sir complexity
okay so we're just going to hard code
those
hard instances here those the sing few
set incident here and then guess what
satisfying Simon for then verify it okay
and that's going to happen in flee often
because because it bales in playoff okay
if it doesn't have it and because the
the comment of almost everywhere is
anything off okay alright but then once
you once you have your hands on a
function with hi sir complexity you can
use standard results in harnesses
retinas to do de anima zation okay so
you can dear Anna mais Merlin Arthur
games simply often in fact within bits
of advice so so you get the following
chain of inclusions that X is equal to
Ma that collapse happens because X and P
Polly okay you you get MA contained in
this in play often in time tutoring
class by guessing a heart function
guessing Merlin's what Merlin's going to
do then using your heart function to
simulate Arthur the radness okay finally
you use the assumption that in X's and
ppalli to take this in time to the end
thing and put it in Polly size because
its but because it's to the end time you
can put it in fixed Polly size and this
thing is just a direct contradiction you
can easily construct the function and
there was in time and say two to the end
of the 2k which doesn't have circuits
like this which is by drying just by
brute forcing officers this is a
contradiction so it must have a
satisfying sense it's a very very
indirect argument yeah
I need to take like the poly size
circuits and then turn them into AC C
circuits like you have to do a trick
like that
we don't mean we can do that that
happens the next slide thank you if P is
an AC C then all unrestricted poly size
circuit families have equivalent poly
sized AC circuit families this just
follows from the fact that the circuit
evaluation problem is in P if P is an
ACC than the circuit evaluation problem
where you're given arbitrary circuit
arbitrary input you only evaluated
that's an AC C so if you ever want to
take a circuit which is arbitrary and
stimuli the ACC you just plug it into
your ACC circuit for evaluating circuits
it's really that simple okay
so if X is an AC sees insisting 3sat is
poly sized a easy circuit encoding set
of signs that's essentially the only
place where we needed in the previous
proofs this thing about X again be right
and that in that limit we have we just
plug in this corollary and the rest of
the argument goes through but now for NX
okay now you may wonder what happened to
the exponential it advantage somewhere
in here okay that's okay the exponential
vanishes somewhere in there though don't
worry about okay for now right all right
so all right so I'm kind of out of time
should I mention this thing about this
distinguishing problem then okay okay so
so I was telling you over and over that
you don't need saddle rhythms you just
need to solve this thing machine problem
where you're given a circuit see inside
they're unsatisfied this assignments
I'm satisfying okay so this is solvable
faster than to the intime okay and think
of C is having polynomial size some
arbitrary opponent sighs okay then X was
not in P poly okay so the proof idea is
actually the same as before except we
replace a different component instead of
using in mandawa is really nice
reduction from elk to the same three set
we use as a saint probably checkable
proof so we reduce from Alvez of the
same policy checkable proof system
okay so we just plug in the following
lemma a bunch of PCP guys from 2005 it
says for every language and in time to
the end there's a reduction polynomial
time reduction actually from L to the
maximum constraint satisfaction problem
with the following properties okay
if our original instance X is in the
language all the constraints of this Big
Macs CSP are satisfiable okay and if X
is not a language at most half the
constraints are satisfiable okay okay
not only do we have this so this is the
normal kind of PCP setup where you you
take a problem you show like you reduce
to either everything satisfiable or
small numbers solve fractions
satisfiable but you have the following
properties moreover you have that the
number of constraints in this problem is
not much bigger than the running time of
the original thing so to the intense
polygon remember we needed that foot so
that our slightly faster set oven would
work and moreover it succinctly
computable in the analogous way the
ayat' constraint this PCP thing is can
people in paulien time and in Manuela
and le bins the Sun has since improved
this thing quite a lot sharpen it quite
a lot
and you have really really strong
results in this direction but if you
think about what's going on now right if
you have this all all satisfiable or
most half satisfiable hey like
essentially this is the only problem you
need to solve in order to sting much
between whether you should accept or
reject now I'll just I'll just let you
think about about that and maybe just
leave the slide up and in stop here
if an open problem slide or do I have an
open problem slide uh yes okay can we
see it yes so I have sort of two of them
problem slides but okay okay
how about this open problem slide so
they're pretty obvious open problems
okay replace an axe with simpler
complexity classes okay yeah I mean like
like exponential time or P space so the
intuition here is that instead of
solving sat or this circuit
approximation probability problem you
may have to solve more complicated
problems faster an exhaustive search if
you can't okay
so here's a nice problem is this faster
counting of SATA Simon's imply stronger
circular rounds like strictly genre for
like a function better than one in X
that's that's that's one kind of problem
that we do know faster Outlands for in
certain cases faster counting okay mate
so maybe there's some leverage to be
gained there another obvious open
problem is replace a GC with stronger
circuits now we have seen some progress
there like for example proved a little
while back that if you've got an ACC and
you put how I erase them you put a layer
of linear threshold functions here right
before you touch the inputs you they
have to go through linear threshold
functions okay yeah I you can prove that
there's a function X it doesn't have
circuits of this kind okay still don't
know how to get linear threshold a
linear threshold okay but you can show
that there's no say sub exponential or
little quasi-polynomial sized circuits
for this for n X functions again using
stronger complexity techniques and and
stronger al rank techniques okay now as
I mentioned maybe we can weaken their
hypotheses like like so far no circuit
lower bound has been proved by going
through the D random
Asian problem but I mean I think that
this is an easier problem to solve so it
makes sense to try to to to maybe go
that way try to prove that an X is not
in TC 0 because at the very least you
can estimate the fraction of TC know
this satisfying assignments with TC 0
circuit faster than to the n ok so
here's another open problem this is
related to proving lower bounds for
boolean formulas or lower bounds for NC
1 so can boolean formulas of size s be
evaluated on all possible assignments
and not to the N times poly STI would be
the cost of exhaustive search but poly s
plus to the N times poly in time so
could you do some maybe pre-processing
on the formula and then solve it faster
so think of as is being super polynomial
may be close to exponential even a 2 to
the n a week 2 to the N on the poly yes
yeah yeah yeah I mean something
yeah something for which this factor is
going to be so yeah much smaller than
the circuit size yeah yeah and something
so that like even for polynomial size
circuits this thing is so even
quasi-polynomial and s here would be
nice in fact this is essentially what
you do to get the acc set algorithm this
is the same like this sort of statement
holds for ACC with a quasi poly and s
there and that is the reason why we get
ACC lower belt is because this
evaluation problem printing all possible
assignments the values can be done
efficiently like this ok so can it be
done for boolean formulas I see no
reason why not but I don't know yes yes
it would imply immediately the NX was
not an NC one yeah yeah but I really
don't see a reason why it couldn't be
done
I'd say for boolean formulas arbitrary
circuits I don't know they connect
together in funny ways but a tree like
formulas very nice tree like one is we
nobody cup decomposing all kinds of nice
ways maybe it could be done okay and in
general fine work in exchange that one's
a little bounce there yeah more all the
time
okay that's all thanks so now you now
you click